hello my name is ahmad allah i'm a
senior principal research manager here
at microsoft research where i lead the
language and information technologies
group
today i'm happy to introduce
presentations in the influential space
of deep learning and large-scale ai
at microsoft research we are approaching
large scale ai from different
perspectives which include not only
building bigger more powerful models but
also developing unique ways of
optimizing models across their entire
life cycle
while also accounting for the effects
you will have on people and society
this means considering things like
efficiency speed and ease of use while
also taking into consideration privacy
fairness trust and other key factors
encompassed in creating more responsible
ai
we are also taking steps toward
understanding how large ai models work
at their fundamental levels what they
are capable of how they learn how they
how to improve their interpretability
these fundamentals are rooted in science
and underscore the important roles of
investigation and experimentation in
guiding innovation and understanding the
limits of deep learning and large-scale
ar
as we continue to make progress in these
areas large-scale models are also
powering new features and experiences
that continue to enable people and
businesses to do more with ai at scale
the ai landscape has been transformed by
the advent of large-scale models like
pert turing and most recently gbt3
researchers have brought language models
to new heights in terms of performance
propelling advancements in search
language translation and more
as models are growing in size and
capability their applications are also
expanding
however larger ai models also present
new challenges
these models are more difficult to
deploy in an affordable and sustainable
way
and despite their huge size they still
need to learn new concepts and tasks
effectively which right now often
requires a lot of help in the form of
label data
most recent models rely heavily on
unstructured texts leaving out important
sources of knowledge that come in forms
of structured content and multi-modal
data
the capabilities that large models bring
to the table have also created a need to
build frameworks for identifying
evaluating and mitigating unintended
outcomes posed by these models
to bring large scale ai to the next
evolution there are four key directions
of research at microsoft that coincide
with these challenges
first is to continue to improve
large-scale model pre-training
another is to create ai models that are
more adaptable and much more efficient
these first two directions also
contribute to pursuing building ai
that's more sustainable
additionally we are working to
understand how will ai impact society
and how can we create ai techniques that
are innovative fair and responsible
lastly we are investigating improved
methods for including multi-modality and
knowledge reasoning into large-scale
hybrid training
today we will learn about these research
directions from several researchers at
microsoft including senior researcher
lee dong who will discuss recent
progress in self-supervised pre-training
chief scientific officer eric horvitz
will lead a panel with several
distinguished researchers in ai from
both academia and external organizations
together they will explore the state of
fairness in ai and its societal
implications
a number of collaborators will also join
my microsoft colleagues to present talks
today
a roundtable hosted by principal
researcher daniel mcduff will delve into
innovation in multimodality and advances
in knowledge reasoning and intelligence
danielle will be joined by jonathan pesk
assistant professor at carnegie mellon
university and drago meradev professor
at yale university
professors bess can radev will talk
about recent advances in these two areas
i will moderate a panel diving into many
ways we can improve efficiency and
adaptability in next generation ar
i will be joined by microsoft
distinguished scientist jen fingao
premistan university assistant professor
dunchy chin
and song han assistant professor in
mit's electrical engineering and
computer science program
professor chin will be also talking
about data efficiency in machine
learning and professor han will discuss
making large-scale ai more
computationally efficient
we also have jiuan liu associate
professor at quingua university in
beijing joining us to discuss work on
knowledgeable pre-trained language
models
thank you to all of the collaborators
who are joining us to share their
perspectives on research in deep
learning and large-scale ai
ultimately large scale ai is a key
technology for enabling machines to
understand the world around us more
fully in ways that will extend our
capabilities and amplify our ingenuity
thank you for joining us today
as we explore research toward making
large-scale ai more efficient adaptive
and safe for everyone